Welcome to Module Ten — production deployment.
This is the last mile: getting a trained model out of the notebook and in front of real users.
We'll cover quantization, TFLite, TensorFlow Serving, TFX pipelines, and monitoring.
Start by making the model smaller and faster with quantization.
Post-training dynamic quantization shrinks the weights.
Full integer quantization takes activations down to int-eight using a small calibration set.
Float-sixteen simply halves the size with no calibration.
And when accuracy matters most, quantization-aware training fine-tunes with fake quantization in the loop — expect roughly two-to-four times faster inference and about four times smaller.
For phones and edge devices, that's TensorFlow Lite.
Convert from a Keras model, run it through the Interpreter on Android, iOS, or even microcontrollers, and lean on delegates — GPU, NNAPI, Hexagon — to accelerate.
Always verify accuracy on the target hardware, because some ops may be unsupported.
On the server side, TensorFlow Serving takes over.
Export to the SavedModel format, lay it out as model name then version number, and serve REST on port eighty-five-oh-one or gRPC on eighty-five-hundred — gRPC being roughly twice as fast.
A few warmup requests prevent cold-start latency spikes, and the official Docker image makes deployment routine.
To make the whole thing reproducible, TFX strings it into a pipeline: ingest, validate statistics and schema, train, evaluate, and push to serving — where schema drift blocks bad data before it ever reaches production.
Orchestrate it with Kubeflow, Airflow, or Vertex AI.
And the job isn't done at deploy.
Watch for data drift as inputs shift and concept drift as the input-to-output relationship changes.
Run a KS test or PSI on your features regularly, roll out with shadow and canary deploys, and log predictions against eventual ground truth so you can retrain.
Let's ship your model — open the labs.
And congratulations: that's the course.